déçu par affi s'affirme
il aurait compris que faire de la
peinture se consacre aux chevaux retrait
de la fed pendant sa jeunesse
évidemment il ne pouvait pas du tout la
vie d'artiste
[Musique]
c'était avant toi art danse sensuelle un
gourmand en gourmande de devises où tout
est ce qu'il a cherché d'ailleurs dans
les maisons closes
c'est un contact un contact d'artistes
qui qui qui veut toucher autrement que
de que de l'oeil presque stay ddd des
mains et de snus on désire l'être
féminin qu'il adorait pont
il était là au moulin rouge presque tous
les soirs quand dans che il nous
regardait fixement
oh
quand elle posait vote réprimandé de
chanter un couplet de chilpéric d'hervé
qu'elle veut avec le jouet aux variétés
mais ce couplet lautrec lui faisait
répéter chanter une fois 5 x 10 x 50 x
ils viennent demander mais monsieur
lautrec vous ne voulez pas que nous
chante d'autres couples est à mais non
ça me gênerait
alors pourquoi me faites vous chantez à
je vais vous dire ma demoiselle sait que
la peau de votre dos zizi à la lumière
et c'est ce que je cherchais
[Musique]
vous